therapy
has changed not only my life but
millions of people's lives and and um i
i know david harwood who was on who's on
supergirl he came on the show
and he was so forthcoming and so
open about his you know
his history of like with mental illness
and all these things and i just was in
the first thing you said is i go to
therapy which not all actors do they
kind of want to hide that yeah
yeah i mean but most actors go i just
think
is that true yeah i think so they just
don't maybe share that they do but it's
important and
uh
for me i i started seeing someone weekly
uh cause i've got been on and off but
pretty much
uh right right when the pandemic started
i was like okay because i had to sit
still i couldn't work
right i couldn't do it i'm forced to
just stay at home
yeah but that's fine i found things to
do what did you do i started writing so
is is then that that's how it all
happened yeah yeah see what happens
you're forced to write at home yeah and
then you end up writing an episode for
the series final season of supergirl for
an episode that's crazy it's like oh you
know what i'm gonna start painting and
then i'm gonna be in the museum next
year look i also
cried and was scared and did all the
things everyone did during the day i
just would carve out a couple hours to
channel that into something and you had
never written before
no i had written but not like a
structured script and i uh got a
teacher
because
you hired a teacher i did i hired a
writing person how do you find a teacher
who will teach you how to write i mean
how did where do you find these people i
had
a friend well i asked a refer i'm gonna
be really honest i i i worked with
someone who felt really intense uh who
was an actual writing coach who wasn't a
working writer and the energy was really
off and it gave me a lot of anxiety
right i called a female showrunner
friend of mine and said hey do you have
any
writers that want to make some money and
are off right now and she's like
actually the perfect person for you and
uh it was a staff writer in one of her
shows and we zoomed and it was like we
got along really well and then two three
days a week we'd hop on so what was the
first conversation you have so ozzy have
you written
um what do you want to write why do you
want to start writing yeah here's from
the
do you just start from where do you
start what do they tell you to do
just write i i
i want i had an idea for a
supergirl uh storyline for kelly um
for your character yeah yeah because
we had kind of touched on her being a
war vet but there was so much of ptsd
and and how we as a country treat
veterans when they come back home and we
hadn't really looked at that um
and we had sean aston on who played like
love sean
how much do you love working with sean
he's like
they always say like henry winkler is
the nicest guy in the business and i
think sean astin's like number two he
really is and and his daughter is a big
fan of super bowl so he's seen every
episode it's their bonding thing they do
together are you kidding me no you've
seen
every and there's over 100 episodes of
supergirl they've watched how many have
you been in
uh i don't know like 40 or 50.
and so you got the idea and i want to
get into this yeah but i also want to go
back to something you just talked about
you said therapy yeah did you get into
therapy just during covered was that the
first time or you had been going for
years i had done it before off and on
but i hadn't consistently
and i had i had like my dog passed and
me too when did your dog pass uh march
my dog passed
five months ago
so what was that it's about about the
same yeah it was hard 13 years oh my
gosh it's it's brutal and uh
i was
you know alone in vancouver you know my
dog was like my
other half yeah
so and then a friend of mine had
suddenly passed and wow
and then and then a week later kovid and
our show got shut down so i was like
prime
i'll tell you something i have a really
good girlfriend of mine when all that
stuff went down who
was like i didn't know how to support
you
and
so
what i'm gonna what i did was i called a
bunch of trauma therapists in vancouver
and i uh narrowed it down to two and i
went ahead and booked sessions with them
and told them everything you've been
through so you don't have to so
here you go and it was like the most
thoughtful and credible what i know
she's a really good friend wait so this
person called up a therapist and said
this is what they've gone through they
lost a dog they've been dealing with
this told as much and this person knew
you inside out she like yeah and talked
to a couple and was like she's not gonna
like that person these two women feel
like a good vibe and then yeah and then
talk them through it so that i didn't
have to you know rehash everything so
you just went right into it